es un golpe contra la mayor organización
de derechos humanos de rusia la corte
suprema de este país decidió disolver
memorial
y el tribunal falla para satisfacer la
solicitud administrativa y judicial del
fiscal general de rusia y así disolver
la organización no gubernamental
internacional de la sociedad histórica
educativa benéfica y de derechos humanos
memoria
la fiscalía acusó a memorial de violar
la ley que requería que ser registrada
como un grupo extranjero a pesar de ser
una organización completamente rusa un
fallo que generó protestas en las
puertas del tribunal supremo- memorial
surgió al final de la unión soviética
para documentar los crímenes del
estalinismo pero desde 2015 han sido
tildados de agentes extranjeros
especialmente desde que comenzaron a
denunciar algunas de las prácticas del
gobierno de vladímir putin como impedir
sus investigaciones sobre ellos han
caído acusaciones de supuestamente
defender extremistas y de distorsionar
la realidad histórica de la unión
soviética algo que niegan
memorial es solamente una organización
con su propia ideología está dicho
combinamos actividades relevantes de
derechos humanos con estudios de la
trayectoria histórica de rusia en el
siglo 20
pero parece que esto no agrada a alguien
en el liderazgo ruso
desde memorial sostienen que esta
decisión es totalmente política y que se
trata de un movimiento más del kremlin
para acorralar a toda la oposición que
existe hacia vladimir putin